there's nothing like a really great game
with getting hyped up ova and for me and
a lot of other people right now that
game seems to be child of light now
whether you know all about the game or
you're seeing child of what I'm gonna
let you know why this RPG should be on
your most anticipated list child of
light is a 2d fairy tale if the match up
of water color graphics poetry for
dialogue and a very unique and
well-executed combat system and its most
basic level child of light is a
platformer which alternates between
being a side-scroller complete with
puzzles and exploration sitting at the
forefront and turn-based combat
scenarios the most striking thing about
this game in the trailers is its
aesthetic soft colors and gorgeous
character and level designs have been
applied liberally and accented by a
great soundtrack the animations that
we've seen so far looks smooth and
various dusky purples and yellows that
make up a number of the previewed
landscapes seem like they would be a
welcome change of pace for the game is
swamped in the urban gritty environments
of recent releases like high school and
diablo another reason you're going to
want to keep an eye on this one is the
clever combat system child of light
utilizes turn-based combat which is
rarely a bad thing but it does so in a
way that avoids over complication
tactical decision making factors in but
the main thing you'll want to focus on
when it comes to battles is your timing
as combat is divided up into wait time
and cost time where each player sets in
the timeline of either mode is shown in
a bar at the bottom of the screen as
explained in detail by mark Walton in
his video feature on gamespot and
interrupts mechanic where you can
sabotage potentially deadly attacks as
an enemy is casting is imperative to
master
I'm always on the hunt for the next
really good RPG and child of light is
promising to deliver on not just
aesthetics but also gameplay it's RPG
elements are a little simplified
compared to games like Oblivion but
that's not at all a bad thing you'll
find all the typical RPG features like
buffs XP weapon upgrades and skill trees
which so far seem to be enough to keep
an RPG fan satisfied without gamers
needing to spend too much time thinking
about maximizing their abilities and
equipment and overshadowing the
narrative in the process from what we've
seen party members all have their own
fairly extensive skill trees that
consists of three distinctive branches
for specialization child of light is
totally intriguing from what we've seen
so far it's a great example of what a
new generation console game can deliver
both in terms of a quality game and one
that's delightfully unique last week I
told you guys about my favorite Easter
eggs in gaining and asked you to let me
know what yours were in the comments and
you delivered chasity said The Witcher 2
in the prologue when you find an
assassin of the Assassin's Creed series
dead by a destroyed hey cartwheel that
is an excellent example which very
nearly made my personal cuts on YouTube
Alvarez's L said his favorite Easter
eggs were in GTA vice city which had a
hidden room with an actual easter egg on
a plinth also Saints Row 2 where if you
followed the arrow signs far out into
the sea a giant purple Easter Bunny
would surface out of the water good
times foul rogue Bane pointed out many
people don't know this but in gta4
special edition there was a
crazy-looking clown walking around on
the street with a knife that he very
rarely appeared so it was very hard to
find him well that's creepy and
upsetting as for this week let me know
if you're gonna be picking up child of
light and which game of 2014 you're most
looking forward to as for the gist next
week we will be taking a break but I
will see you again soon